hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy
i am excited today to talk with kara
bobroff who is the founder of the native
american community academy and naca
inspired schools we're going to talk
about culture in education broadly and
the education of native american
students in particular
so looking forward to that
before we get started a couple of notes
to a reminder that khan academy is a
non-profit organization and we are able
to do our work thanks to the generous
donations from people like you if you go
to acon academy.org
donate you will see
and have the opportunity to be able to
donate to help us continue our mission
similarly we want to thank some of our
supporters who really stepped up during
the covid crisis to help us with our
work and that includes bank of america
at t google.org novartis fastly and
general motors
reminder
if you want to hear this
talk again or if you have missed some
and want to catch up you can get audio
versions of the these these talks at the
homeroom with sal podcast available
wherever you get your podcasts
so
with that let me welcome karen fabroff
it's nice to have you
it's nice to be here i'm super excited
for our conversation and i'm really
looking forward to it
great so i'd like to start off asking
people
how did you get to where you are today
tell us a little bit about your path to
to
starting these schools and this network
and all the work you do
yeah um thank you guys for that i um
it's it's an interesting story of like
two or two or three different dynamics
of um of a journey both personal um
professional and then also like um kind
of a calling of what needed to happen
within our community um so i'm navajo
and lakota i'm gonna introduce myself in
that way day uh cara barbara finishes
natalie bush's chin um so on my
mother's side biological mother's side i
am navo and our families from a
community in new mexico called rhema
which is not contiguous without donation
but part of navigation um and on that
side we're the salt plan and that's how
we identify so we recognize our
relatives of any relatives out there
today that are also the salt planet in
navajo i just wanted to say um you know
open up kind of a conversation on that
level just to say that's an important
relationship the second part is um
lakota and on that side my biological
father is from pine ridge area and so
near pine ridge and rosebud i grew up in
albuquerque new mexico and basically my
parents were both educators my mom was a
middle school teacher her entire life my
father was a teacher assistant principal
principal
became a systems leader as well of our
school district but not really knowing i
was going to become a teacher so
um really i had a
important aspect of something that
happened when i was about 19 years old i
served as a mental health worker in a
residential treatment center and that
was the first time i started to work
with youth who were six years seven
years eight years younger than i um who
are going in and out of um
various systems from foster care to you
know the psychology festival to home for
all sorts of reasons and i think that
really um set in stone for me that those
students have been or the children have
been through more in their life than i
would ever have to really endure and
kind of like really drew me into
education although my family's influence
had for sure became a special education
teacher at the school i went to started
to see all the good things about being a
teacher and also started to see some
inequities around who had access to what
kind of courses and how that was
determined predetermined for a lot of
kids and
reflected back on my own experience and
saw that that was probably true when i
was there just like there was a group of
us and a third of us went to one
classroom a third of us went to another
and a third of us went to another and um
not really sure why but then we would
kind of like re reconnect so that was
interesting to experience um surgeon
assistant principal at school my older
siblings went to which freaked them out
like how did you meet the sister where
we went to school um my journey took me
to the bay area and i
served as a dean of students in marin
county at a school called miller creek
middle school and that was the first
time i started to see a couple things
one that school provided so many
opportunities for their students and
families and was really sponsored to
their community um it wasn't a question
of which college kids would go to um it
was a question of like what college i
mean if they would go to college it was
a question of like which college they
would go to um which was very different
much more responsive social and
emotionally students however there was a
lack of diversity um so also from an
equity standpoint just kind of saw like
the difference between what students and
teachers had there was a public school
than what i kind of experienced myself
um and how schools were operated at that
time also during that time back home
i was there for four years there was a
conversation around native american
education and a need for a native
american banner charter school that was
probably the first time i heard about
about that and always thought that'd be
a cool place to work
when i moved back home
however um you know i think that that
was kind of grounded in the fact that
many of our elders um and those who had
come before in an urban setting had
always had a longing to do something
more for native youth in albuquerque
specifically
knowing that that district serves about
80 000 kids six to seven thousand
self-identified is native and
in like that time to now when we look at
the senses that population of urban
indigenous families has increased not
only in albuquerque but across the
united states um
so just kind of got an interest and that
um would go back and forth um from
different you know
times just having that conversation and
nothing really kind of came to you um my
journey took me to shiprock new mexico
where i was um served as a principal at
nuka middle school which was like the
best school on earth in the sense of
like a place i really felt connected i
am
kind of thought like i didn't speak my
language fluently so i didn't know if i
would be the best principal for for the
community but what i found was a couple
things one that the strengths of the
students and families and the cultural
knowledge was so great that it should be
incorporated into the school as like how
the students in marin had so many things
brought into their school you know
opportunities as well but there was a
dialogue that was going on that was
really troublesome in the sense that at
that time the school board thought well
we shouldn't be teaching naval language
because that inhibits students ability
to read and if you think about research
in general or just like things that we
know to be true when you're bilingual
trial and multi-label those are all
major strengths
there's a lot of bias to unpack a lot of
institutionalized
i would say deficit mindsets around the
students like are these students going
to go to college and even like teachers
that i was becoming the principal of was
would say to me they you know they the
families here don't necessarily value
education
um and so why would we ask our students
whether they want to go to college and
so i try to like remain calm and
diplomatic at the same time use data to
prove that that wasn't true which we did
by you know kind of you know engaging
our parents in that conversation and and
found that like you know 98 of families
want their kids to go on to a two to
four year college experience so just
that was a really um tough situation
because there was a lot of opportunity
the school was like fledgling and almost
went into like a school improvement
process that would have put them in
danger of like being taken over by the
state at that time we were able to turn
it around and really started to think
about differentiation more involvement
of student voice all those good things
that
people would want their kids to have in
a school
and we saw progress so
so as well as like my own personal
journey around my own identity growing
up not on the reservation but in a study
um
being you know disconnected from my
family and then having to reconnect was
really a powerful thing that i i was
experiencing but came back home
wanted to follow up on the idea of naca
and really started to engage the
community in that process so
i would say it's a lot of those
different things um and then also just
you know i would say my family had a lot
of um like impact on me both like
immediately and also um some of my
grandparents who really like forged the
way around education within their own
communities too
wow that is excellent
so that kind of leads us right into tell
us a little bit about the the native
american community academy and
if we went and visited what would it
what would we see what would it look
like
so naka is like synonymous with me with
the same like word as far as love like
there is so much like interconnectedness
and like relationships among students
teachers and families it's truly a
community i think of not like in the
essence of being like something that was
not in existence that came into
existence it just connected people
together in ways that grew an entire
like web of
support for generations so it's our 16th
year
you would see students learning inside
and outside so like land-based learning
as well as learning like in a
traditional i guess classroom you would
see students on a college campus and you
would also see
early learning taking place in an
elementary school
access to four or five different
languages that they can take throughout
the time that they're at the school
lakota zuni navajo language keras tiwa
tawa partnerships with community
organizations school uh access to
school-based health centers
students being able to not only know
like who they are and where they come
from but being able to articulate a
vision they have that's meaningful to
them based on their own world view
um
one of the foundational pieces of naca
as we were putting the school together
and like what i mean by that is we
literally went out and talked to
community members over a period of like
a year and a half two years about you
know what is it that we want to see for
native american students and three
things rang true
one is that there would be both access
and like success going to college
and that was based on a lot of people's
experience about not having that within
their own education and or going to
college and not succeeding within the
first year and for all sorts of
different reasons um the second is that
the students would be secure in their
identity and understanding like what is
their identity not only as an indigenous
person but maybe somebody who's
bicultural and somebody who also has
like a passion in the area of the arts
but being able to be in connection with
that in a very real way um is one
major outcome and the last is that
students would be healthy and this is
where the knock of wellness well it's on
our website anybody can access it is um
foundational to the to the start of the
school we talked a lot about like what
patterns and like um aspects of native
american education had not worked in the
past and we talked about like some of
the things that we saw as far as
data and outcomes for for native
students but we wanted to start with a
strengths-based mindset
and we selected the wellness wheel which
is kind of
based off of
basically
a lot of different tribes think of like
people as being like whole individuals
like you're not just coming to school to
access like one aspect of who you are
you bring all of yourself so
intellectually however students you know
faring
physically like your physical wellness
as well as your social emotional
wellness
and your connection to your community
and overall spirituality and
spirituality not being religiousity but
no realizing like what are those things
that renew us what are those things that
we can help reflect upon so
our students spend a lot of time
working with the wellness world as well
as other courses and classes
um
95 of the students day is grounded in
indigenous perspectives meaning that
we're bringing in either whether that's
authors or whether that's like
knowledge from elders or knowledge from
our content teachers in the languages or
indigenous science and understanding you
know ecological aspects of different
things that have taken place but those
things are integrated into how students
are what how and what students are
learning
and how being really really important i
think too um so those are all the things
that you would say i can talk about naca
for for several hours but i always feel
like like when i think of like our our
students are learning things that may be
you know hard to learn so i think of
like um kids in the middle school who
are understanding like the role of
education in native communities around
boarding schools right and so they
rocker they experience a lot of emotion
around that they're doing an
intergenerational interview with their
grandmother who went to boarding school
just reflecting back to them i'm glad
you're at naca and you have access to
language and culture i didn't um
you know all of those like really
powerful things they take that interview
and transcribe it into an actual you
know
written piece um use that piece and they
like
a student demonstration where they're
like perform like
presenting that back to their community
and then proactively as an entire class
they decide to do something that's much
more
positive and productive as to like not
get caught into the negativity or the
the victimization of like our history
but really be more um i guess i guess
like a visionary in the sense of like
they have like the ability to really you
know empower themselves to think about
what it is they want to see different so
so a lot of different aspects of that
and we really hope that naca is a place
where our students can not only explore
their identity but act upon it in ways
that make sense like whether that's slam
poetry um it could be you know a service
oriented project um it could be you know
anything that really resonates with them
um
yeah so that's just a little bit about
naka but um it's pretty amazing place
yeah
um thanks for sharing all that it
definitely i have so many questions and
i know we want to talk about the the
network feature
but one of the things that i know i see
in learning research is that
when students feel like they belong and
have that feeling of belongingness we
see better learning outcomes as well and
it sounds like that that
that building in that culture
then
it seems related to that research of
where things are so do you see that
relationship between
for instance the identity and
that and academic achievement as well
yeah i would say the the belonging and
connectedness of the essence of the
community of our school is huge um i
think of like a story of one of our
students her mom
shared this with me but
she came to naca and for the first
semester at least six months um was
really you know quiet didn't really
share too much but was always
participating like did what she needed
to do and like you know it was a was a
really cool kid and just like but didn't
really like articulate a lot and and
shares too much to with her peers or in
the classroom setting and then she kind
of turned a corner and i remember her
mom came back and said you know like
um
like my daughter the entire time she was
in school up until the time she came
didn't talk in school and now i can't
get her to stop talking like total
transformation in the sense of like now
she's like leading classroom discussions
like she's leading projects she's like
involved in like different kind of
extra-curricular activities and so i
feel like that
we i know from my own personal
experience
um when you're in a setting that sees
who you are um is reflected in what
you're learning
values you that is who you are and what
that is that you open up and you're able
to
not have to navigate like they worry
about like how is people's perceiving me
or
and are they going to make fun of the
fact that i have to go to a ceremony for
you know a few days with my family and
come back or that there's a song that's
a traditional song that we want to share
so all of those things are simple points
of strength and like um and it becomes
like becomes like just that's how the
school is right um it's not this is how
our community you know has been
operating since you know
time memorial let alone the fact that
you know kids can be leading in that
space so that's like one small story i
am you know i do remember
the like the worst kind of situation of
that is like when you're in a school
setting that's not value and it's
actually like you experience some sort
of microaggression and or like racial um
you know slur of some sort and then that
like shuts kids down really really
quickly so we do see that i'd say that
we also see like some of the students
who are involved in like learning their
language it gives them a bigger insight
into
their history as well as their identity
and that helps set them up for later
success some are alumni who went to
different schools like ranging from
ivy's small liberal arts schools
community colleges tribal colleges all
kind of report back like
well like these are the teachers who had
the biggest impact on us which were
largely the teachers who have most of
that cultural knowledge and
connectedness yeah and also they you
know they're like it's better off like
when we went to this you know you know i
went to so-and-so school i started this
like effort around native american you
know students but also all of the other
students of color were going through an
identity crisis and they were having a
really hard time struggling in a
different setting um and i didn't really
go through that like i felt super
grounded in who i was um a lot of the
content we had already like you know
engaged with and so i felt better
prepared in that sense so i think that
definitely the belonging is a huge piece
and also understand your identity and
also we're talking about generations of
folks who've been separated you think
about what boarding schools did to our
communities and just not having that be
the perspective of education that most
students across the country engage with
can you give a little bit of that
history for folks that aren't familiar
of the the boarding schools and
what that
results in
yeah i um so there's like a quote that
talks about
um basically like killing the indian and
saving the man so this idea that both
assimilation and kind of direct
colonization of children being removed
from their homes would
be more beneficial to native american
communities across the united states and
this was like back in the you know 1800s
and
thinking about and also iterations of
that all the way through
um
the time that we
are now and today so i think of it a
couple ways one you know pre-contact
there wasn't any kind of interaction
between
um you know native communities and
westernized culture and there wasn't
even an institution of education um we
call that like indigenous education then
we did have um like the treaties that
were negotiated across our um across the
world across the country um i think of
my tribe you know the navajo nation in
particular and one thing that um holds
true in that sense is that the way i was
told was that our leaders at that time
were forcibly removed and all of our
people from one side of our state to the
other and in prison and encampment um in
that encampment in order to go back
after two and a half years they had to
negotiate a treaty part of that treaty
negotiation was that
the navajo nation would take on one
teacher for 25 kids that would be
provided by the united states government
and the leaders were having this
discussion in navajo with a spanish
interpreter to spanish and spanish to
english and english back to spanish and
so it was quite you know something that
was a great concern otherwise we would
have been removed to oklahoma or
potentially florida so in order to go
back to our four sacred mountains are
they said yes but they asked like what
are the patterns of this education
system how does it work how does it
function um before that like learning
was seamless um within communities and
also within like the origins of our
seasons so that's one example um as we
move through like as you get into the
50s and 60s and 70s a resurgence of um
tribal colleges as well as other schools
focused on language and culture through
self-determination and so you started to
see schools like now um referral
demonstration schools and and the rhema
day school that were started to bring
language and culture and community-based
education back into communities um
versus having students have to leave
their community
and now we're in a time where i feel
like there's such a movement around
indigenous people and also recognizing
the importance of culturally english
responsive education as well as like
what's being taught that's really really
important um and so and it's important
to kids first and foremost i think
that's what makes their education better
and also helps them be more successful
and being able to
to um
do what they need to do knowing who they
are and understanding that history and
also all students i think need to
understand that for sure
yeah but yeah and so
that leads to then the question that i
do all students need to understand this
how do we take the things that you've
learned through naca and think about
scale and where those are so i know one
step was the naca inspired school so
tell me a little bit about that
yeah so like within the first two years
of naca we were asked several times like
can we start a knockout in our community
um so when people come to visit they're
like oh my god this is possible this is
what people were writing about in the
50s and 60s this is what you know our
you know elders were saying needs to be
incorporated back into school right so
we were like yes but it needs to come
from your community so we're like how do
we do that so we put together the knock
inspired schools network um i worked
with some folks to think about like what
that would look like basically we
support fellows who work with their
communities and engage them in a similar
process as we did at nacas to
come up with their own mission and
vision of a school that makes sense for
them around indigenous education so
there's um let's see maybe five six
schools in new mexico right now some up
in south dakota that are coming online
um denver as well as another one down in
u um and so really it's just like having
a conversation about if we were to build
something for our children um and native
american
kids like wherever that may be um what
would that look like what would we want
to accomplish and how would we go about
that so some schools are really heavily
focused on language and culture some are
really um immediate dual language models
some are focused on immersion all have
like the components of holistic wellness
culture and indigenous perspectives some
are really focused on land-based
learning
others are doing like you know
internships different things like that
it just depends but that's one way we
started to share the others we created
indigenous knowledge management hub
which is open to anybody to
find like what our teachers have created
and to contribute and or just utilize
those types of lessons k through k
through 12. um
i feel like
so much of this is like
like equally important to students that
are in a traditional maybe comprehensive
like you know elementary school middle
school or high school um to understand
like not only the content that we have
provided but also just being able to
understand the history of our
environment of the united states and
like the role that native people
have played and continue to um so those
are some things that we've done to help
share
can you say the name of the that again
that has all the lessons oh yeah
it's on the uh not inspired schools
website it's called the indigenous
knowledge management hub which is
probably not the most
so if anybody out there has like a
suggestion on like what to name that
feel free to like send that back right
away
excellent excellent um so you you
dr a couple of times had mentioned that
now i've forgotten what you what it's
called but the land-based um teaching
can yeah can you just tell us a little
bit about what that is and what that
looks like yeah so we so when we first
started naca we started with a focus on
experiential education as well as like
um a project around healthy food and
indigenous farming in gardening and so
getting kids like that are involved in
actually working on the land to do
things that to to center their learning
um so that was like the first like kind
of iteration of that um now that has
grown into a team at naca that started
focusing on
things such as like water and water
defenders and understanding like what
the importance of water within our
communities
medicine and like how do we identify
medicine when we're out and about in
different
you know
areas whether that's in our home
communities or within the city or within
the mountains next to us
as well as food and understanding the
importance of food and healthy food how
food is grown how food systems work um
and how do they exist or not exist
within our communities as well and then
also thinking about just
other ways to blend um learning around
sciences whether that's through
literature whether that's through math
whether that's through different content
areas that teachers can connect to by
taking their students out to to the land
to be able to do that so
you know whether that's an inquiry-based
science project or it's a you know
taking a group of students to harvest
pinyon for the um for that time and
understanding why um the significance
culturally and also the significance of
pinyon within the community what that
means and then distribution like what
does that mean as well so part of that
we actually are now launching an
indigenous farmer's hub which is
building out a csa model to then like
grow food and be able to provide that
food back to to our students and
families and community at large um where
students are actively engaged in
understanding um how do you develop a
healthy food system and what does it
mean to grow harvest food and create um
like those opportunities and indigenous
farming so so that's an example um but
something i think that also connects our
students to land and to other people
within our community who may not be a
traditional teacher like in the in the
sense that they come up through um a
pipeline that might be through a
university but there are those community
members who hold all this different
knowledge and like expertise that they
can learn from
great
so
if if you think about uh teachers and
maybe a traditional public school and
where those are who want to do and bring
more of this into their classroom what
advice do you have for them about how to
think about making their classrooms more
culturally responsive
yeah i think knowing your students and
families and starting there and just i
mean and really getting to build a
relationship
when i think about being culturally like
responsive or culturally responsive in
education this is like something you
know i've spent about 18 20 months at
the state thinking about like what are
the lessons learned that we can share
um one of those like like really
understanding like what's the historical
context of the community in which you
serve um as a teacher whether you have
to do that in isolations or you can do
that as an entire school um two engaging
your community and like what it is they
want to see um and and for their
children and getting an understanding of
that so it helps guide the processes and
protocols and like outcomes that you're
you're aiming for
i also believe that like
we have to have like open conversations
and courageous conversations and we
never ever want to set up a student to
come into a classroom where they feel
like they don't belong
so the sense of belonging within a
classroom setting and or a school
setting is something that is really
really important in opening up your
curriculum so that students can explore
that in a way that's um healthy for them
and safe and also that brings in the
different dimensions of all the students
that you serve so one of our parents
reflected back to us in our first year
like when you said you were going to
serve like 62 different tribes and 13
different ethnicities and be able to do
that for your curriculum i thought it
was like like i wanted wanted to see
that i also was incredibly ambitious and
i had no idea how you were going to do
that without many different tribes and
perspectives and so we talked about like
how our
teachers were able to facilitate like
open-ended kind of universal questions
enduring understandings and essential
questions that lended themselves to
students being able to do that and when
he then and a focus group
came back and told us like my son you
know comes home and he tells me not only
did he share about where he's from and
what he knows about our family and our
culture and our background and like what
he was reading he also heard from like
the other you know
15 students in his um cohort about what
it was that um their ex family's
experience and so so then it becomes
like just a way to be able to share that
without any kind of hesitation um in and
i think that you know students now like
really understand
their own identities in ways that i
don't believe many of us ever had that
opportunity in school to be able to do
that so creating real community and
being
open ended in like how you're thinking
about teaching and also letting students
lead i think is like a good place to
start
yeah i i've
heard that community message from you
coming through loud and clear that it
really has to be
everything based on understanding
that the community that you're serving
in and and
where those are how do you if you have
new teachers coming into the school how
do you prepare them what kinds of
training do they go through
yeah so a couple of things one um you
know as we were growing the school every
year we'd have like a new set of
teachers coming in to to trying to to
that's a lot of it's just modeling so
like when we started the first day of
school it was very different um we
started with a song from one of our
navajo instructors as well as a song
from one of our lakota instructors and
it was we were outside in a circle with
families um and students at the same
time really just acknowledging like this
is very different
but this is like shouldn't be different
right it should be the norm and it is
now the norm right so so just like being
able to have um and i would always
invite um
our
new teachers to those type of
experiences before they come on board so
that they're seeing how maybe we close
the end of one year out and those
significant traditions that we have
whether it was like you know our
ceremonies at the end around student
recognition and graduation and what
those look like um
whether it was like a community um kind
of a event of some sort too whether it's
the annual powwow or feast day that we
have in the fall
um
but other than that it's like building
in the time first of all it's like
giving teachers like three hours a week
to be able to have time with their teams
having a mentor within the school
that understands the school culture core
values and what does that mean when we
talk about indigenous perspectives and
education if you're native or non-native
and you're a teacher at the school
as well as
we created a
couple of different things one is called
growing educators for native american
communities where we co-created with a
community college a certification
program that uses the naca framework a
curricular framework to redesign all of
the courses that those teachers would
take and then we took that and that's
our professional development model now
so it's grounded on the um kind of
notion of ke which is a word from the
demonation which talks about
relationships and then goes into like
the cycle that is a navajo learning
cycle
which is aligned with the four
directions which basically is about
reflection planning implementation and
then reflection again which is something
that has been in place within our
communities for a very long time
um so doing the work by using like the
different aspects of what we know to be
true um the second was the indigenous
educators corps which is an america love
americorps um which gives you know 20
some young
folks or elders to the opportunity to be
within schools and to
serve alongside educators in these
different schools that we support and
then hopefully becoming teachers
themselves but i would say by being
connected having the time to do that
and realizing that there's not a book or
a textbook you can pick up that's going
to be able to say like
that's how you like indigenize education
um eventually maybe somebody will write
that one of us should probably do that
at some point but like but working
collaboratively yeah and being able to
to um show what that's like and then
always having
many resources within the individuals
who are around our students and families
that want to see this happen so that's
always always been helpful too
great well i could talk to you all day
but we are already at the end of our
time thank you so much for sharing your
work it is
so interesting and inspiring to hear so
thank you for all you're doing
well thank you and thanks for this
opportunity huge fans of all the work
that you all do in the world too and so
i appreciate this and i hope you all
have a good um rest of your month and
day thank you
and for all those listening we do have
another show on thursday with pedro de
brucier he's the author of urban myths
about learning and education
and more urban myths about learning and
education and he will be announcing for
the first time his new book so 12 p.m
pacific 3 eastern on thursday to hear
more thanks all for joining us
you